president-elect joe biden has unveiled a
1.9
trillion dollar coveted relief package
it includes another 1400
payment to tens of millions of americans
and proposes 160 billion dollars for a
national vaccination program
mr biden wants to shift the political
focus as the senate prepares to take up
the second impeachment of president
trump joining us now are cbs news
political contributors robbie mook and
terry sullivan
robbie was hillary clinton's 2016
campaign manager
and terry manage marco rubio's 2016
campaign
uh good morning to both of you gentlemen
i'm hoping you will equip me with
something smart to say to neighbors
friends family who are asking me right
now what is going on with politics in
our country
robbie i will start with you because
you've got some practical information
for people
the senate joe biden wants to pass this
massive relief package but the senate
also has to consider
a impeachment trial how are they going
to do both
yeah well from what i'm hearing they're
going to try to get this impeachment
done
as quickly as they responsibly can
because i think there is tremendous
urgency
to get to work on the coveted relief
package as
the president-elect said last night time
is of the essence here so
i don't think democrats are interested
in dowling around this is not partisan
i think in their minds by the way this
is really about
creating a consequence and
accountability for the president
inciting this riot can they do both
they can you know the democrats set the
rules around this they're going to have
that majority
and i do think it's realistic for them
to do a speedy trial
and get right on to doing the other
business i'm also hearing alternatives
where
they may actually pass kovid really
first and then go to the trial they have
a lot of different options here right
now i was gonna go to terry on president
trump because that's the big question
here
he will no longer be president but uh if
the senate rules it can be done
under the constitution he may still face
impeachment or conviction
in the senate with this hearing it would
take 17 republicans terry
one reading of the situation is that
republicans would love
to see donald trump go away forever they
just don't want to be seen doing that in
public
do you think 17 republicans will come
along and vote to convict on impeachment
you know it's tough to determine what
the jurors are going to do before the
case has even started um so i don't know
i do think that uh the republican party
is ready to move on
in in in most ways i think both parties
i mean
in the last four years both parties have
become a one
issue party and that issue's been donald
trump and i think that what we're seeing
now is both parties want to quickly move
on and start talking about other issues
well i think the republicans need to
keep looking at those interviews with
the police officers who were
beaten with the american flag and we're
hearing rioters say kill him with his
own gun
so i'm curious terry about mitch
mcconnell in particular who says
he hasn't made up his mind about whether
he's going to vote for a conviction a
do you believe that or b do you think
he's engaging in strategy and if so what
is
what is his game plan here
yes gail yes guess what terry
yes to all of the above look i think he
means it
i think he is it is everything mitch
mcconnell does is engaging in strategy
it's who he is as a person um and he's
very good at it and look
he's keeping uh the president on a short
leash for the remaining days of his
presidency
and putting him on notice no more
screwing around
um and or i'm going to vote to impeach
and so and it seems to be somewhat
working we haven't seen
any uh irrational overly irrational
things in you know the last 72 hours
since he said it and that's a pretty big
deal for donald trump so it seems to be
working the strategically terry i'm
really curious because you've got while
you say
i think the leadership of the party may
be ready to move on from donald trump
are republican voters ready to move on
because i'm looking at polls that's
saying they don't blame
donald trump for what happened at the
capitol
yeah i don't know that it's again it's
not even both parties
it's it's america has become a one-issue
country and it's just fixated on donald
trump
and a lot of what you see that you know
look the guy who's wearing uh
a native american uh headdress or or
bull costume
um and is in in jail in
uh arizona is a shaman i mean he's not a
the demographic of a conservative
republican um so i think what you saw is
a lot of
a lot of crazy people following the lead
of one
crazy person the president united states
and so i i don't know this is an
ideological issue or even a partisan
issue
it's that he has he has made this a
fever-pitched
nation and it's it turned everything
about him and i think america
hopefully is ready to move on and that's
what it's really about
robbie if you go back to 2008 the
democrats took the white house and both
houses of congress and the republican
position wasn't to retool and change
their message it was to fight to dig in
deeper
and to try to make obama at that time a
one-term president do you expect
a similar approach here where they just
obstruct obstruct obstruct
well i'm concerned that's going to be
the case but the big difference now is
back in 2008 we had an economic crisis
um
now we have an economic crisis and a
pandemic that is making the economic
crisis worse
and so i i think for all lawmakers they
should take uh
president-elect biden at his word last
night when he said
everybody's got to work together he is
genuinely trying to reach across the
aisle
i agree with terry that donald trump has
made everything about donald trump
for the last few years we've got to move
on from that
biden gave a completely different speech
last night you know he was honest
he was candid he said he wasn't going to
get everything right i mean this was
a total departure from the defensiveness
the lies the
the quack medical theories we've been
hearing the last few years
and and the the stakes here are really
high this economy is getting worse
and so i hope that we'll see some
republicans
at least try to uh work uh work together
uh both chambers uh both parties
to to get some work done because we're
falling behind yeah the stakes couldn't
be any higher robbie mcterry sullivan
thank you both very much as always